some bad news so Andrew Tate has cancer
his lungs
impossible I don't know you don't you
don't smoke cigars into your lungs so I
couldn't tell you so guys have just saw
something that made my heart sink now we
didn't cover anything on Andrew having
cancer due to nothing being confirmed
and having cancer is not something to
throw in a title to clickbait so you
wanted a member of Andrew's team to
confirm something about his health
honestly I was hoping they didn't purely
because it's super sad Andrew's manager
just posted on his Instagram story
saying okay A lot of people are asking
me if Tate lung cancer story is true yes
it's true I was the one driving with him
to and from the hospitals in Dubai I
don't have any more specifics to share
this tweet explains more and it's the
tweet that Solomon tweeted earlier on
after we posted the video of the leaked
Health documents Solomon said Andrew Tay
Medical Update possible cancer the CT
report is extremely alarming Andrew Tate
may have lung cancer
urgent biopsy needed and a six-month
delay could be fatal the reports he lost
10 kilograms in weight which also is a
sign of cancer cancer could be incurable
now honestly I don't know
that's an implication that he's not
allowed to get his biopsy just because
he's in jail I don't know I don't know
nothing about Romania that's pretty
that's pretty cool if that's the case
honestly I don't even know what to say I
was hoping the help documents were fake
to me this seems like a movie after the
first video I made on tay I really
didn't think it would lead to this
regardless of whether you dislocate or
like him everyone is human and if Andrew
is unwell and needs urgent attention the
Romanian Authority should let him go how
can you know about someone potentially
dying but let them suffer to me the
government want him gone and they'll use
his health as a cover-up honestly guys
I'm deeply sad and wish Andrew how very
sad if this is true lung cancer has
affected our family very widely and it's
you know it's an extremely difficult
thing that doesn't mean they should let
him go uh because he has cancer so here
in the um in the U.S we have something
called compassionate release yeah like
you should at least be allowed to go to
the hospital no compassionate releases
if you have if you're you're dying your
terminal there is no hope for you you
can you can petition the court to let
you go home to die at home and instead
of dying in prison okay expand upon your
point so that that is your terminal
you're dying all treatments have failed
nothing's going to work for you you're
not a psycho who killed a bazillion
people and you know with children
they'll let you go home and die at home
so okay in this case this is not what
we're talking about here we're talking
about a man who may have cancer and
needs a biopsy that's what that said so
on the one hand it's saying he has
cancer on the other hand it said he may
have cancer and needs a biopsy so he has
an unconfirmed condition is what I get
out of this so the guy being like they
should just release him no they should
I want Andrew Tate to be released but
not but that's not the the standard
right which a criminal potential
criminal any other criminal should be
released their manager says he needs a
biopsy so we should just let him go free
just in case he has cancer like that's
stupid I hope he doesn't have cancer and
I hope he gets out because they have
they haven't pressed charges you know
what I'm saying I'm saying yeah I get
what you're saying you just said that in
like a pretty horrible way but I
understand what you're saying what was
horrible about how I set up I don't
think he should get out that was like
the first thing hormonal should get out
because they need a biopsy they should
get their biopsy while they're in jail
they shouldn't be prevented from having
that but you shouldn't just get to go
free because somebody says you might be
sick yeah I get your point I just not a
good one I don't think it applies here
though at all like because he's not a
criminal so it's like but with the
Romanian law the way they can hold
people regardless I just think it's
weird yeah the whole thing is the whole
thing is terrible he shouldn't be there
to begin with but this is their law and
this is what what they've agreed to
except this is what the people of
Romania have agreed to accept from their
government they can just hold you while
they build a case against you because
they feel like it I'd like to think
there was something more complicated
about it than that but we haven't seen
that that's crazy I hope it's I hope
it's not true and I hope he does not
have cancer and if he does I hope he's
able to get the treatment he needs while
he's in prison I wonder if three months
is six months what with lung cancer
untreated you're you could easily go
from stage one to stage four and it'd
just be the end yeah I mean they should
at least let them get treatment and
stuff like [__] I don't know I'm not a I
don't I'm not a doctor who deals with
cancer but I don't know this just seems
it just pisses me off it's indisputable
that it's six months of of lung cancer
depending on the type of lung cancer
though it there's a chance that you're
it's going to grow to from one two three
and four and put you at the end of your
life wow that was vague information and
it is a little sketch to be honest would
just be a sympathy play I very I don't
trust the media I wouldn't trust it I
either if sartorial shooter didn't put
that on his story he's the one do you
remember in the tape documentary when um
the guy he took he took the guy in the
car and the interview remember I know
who that is yeah that's him that said
that yeah it's not really the media but
no that's true okay yeah let's look at
this document a little bit here he's
being investigated for a lesion and is
right upper lung underwent a CAT scan
there were some concerning features of
the lesion that require
urgent investigation and tissue
diagnosis it's his medical
recommendation that Andrew is urgently
repatriated to the watch UAE to undergo
these medical investigations without a
delay okay the fact is he could get
those medical investigations done in
Romania while he's in prison that's what
that's what the answer should be okay we
care about our prisoners Health we're
not here to kill people with cancer
we'll get these tests done here there's
no he doesn't need to he doesn't need to
be released to the UAE for that one of
the things that I've learned a lot about
in the past couple years is discipline
get control of your head control your
mind and learn discipline and so you
stop talking yourself out of things and
so you know Tom Shea the Navy SEAL who
we work with I went through his 21 day
challenge where he gave me some tasks to
do every day and part of the challenge
was to wake up every day commit to doing
it and every time I started to talk
myself out of it I would have an excuse
run through my head some lame ass excuse
and there are four main excuses that he
teaches people that are that ruin lives
that's why we're doing the 21 Day
Challenge again together which Sunny is
not excited about because he's going to
have Tom on his ass if you guys actually
would like to do that with us go to the
link in the description because there's
a discount code come and do it because
guaranteed in one area of your life
there's something you're not doing
because you talk yourself out of it
every day you can go to the top of the
description click the link and buy it
with code sunnyfaz50 for a nice discount
and we'll be doing it with you guys
we'll be in the zoom calls and
everything it'll be cool it's so unusual
for a man of his health and his age to
have lung cancer I don't buy it it's
just natural what do you think people
have the ability to to just give you
something to give you cancer
a specific cancer or
what are you implying yeah it wouldn't
surprise me yeah if they can get that
close in his life where they can give
him cancer they could just put a bullet
in his head or cyanide poisoned him yeah
but if he just dies what looks better
for yeah what looks better from their
POV if he just if he just drops dead
randomly from from taking a sip of water
or if he gets cancer and he smokes all
the time he talks about smoking and the
people don't understand that I don't
know I think cancer invokes empathy for
him sympathy for him so I don't think
the left is sick though they they love
it when their enemies die when have you
ever seen sympathy from them from the
other side that's true they love it I
can guarantee there's going to be
celebrating sick how much they enjoy
there's gonna be some other people
suffer there's going to be celebration
if he dies like from this [__] I don't
know I I just don't buy it like the the
odds of like him being locked up for
this stuff and now he has cancer like
it's all just like it seems like all a
bunch of [__] to me but what do I
know I don't know [__] but all right
thank you guys so much for watching make
sure to like subscribe and I'll see you
later hopefully reacting to morte
content
that's [__] ridiculous
[Music]